- This isn't the chapter I studied for!
(sobbing)
(thud)
I could have ruined my life.
I'm gonna be a meth head on the street.
(thuds against plastic)
You're tricking me to
thinking that it's "this",
but really, really it's "that".
(thud against plastic)
The last 10 I've done 'C' so
there is no other answer but 'C'.
If I spell my name right, does that count?
I heard that counts.
Skip it, skip it, skip it, skip it.
Skip it, skip it.
I'm gonna have the best
time on New Year's Eve
and kiss a boy.
(heavy metal music)
Plenty of rich people
dropped out of college.
I'm gonna be rich!
Siri, what's the answer to question 42.
- [Voiceover] Okay, I
found this on the Web
for "what's the answer
to question 42 feet".
- No!
E quals mc squared times the number
of Meryl Streep's Oscars to the pair of X
divided by the number of snubs she has got
and minus the hours of sleep
that I personally have lost.
That equals 93 billion light years
which is approximately the size
of the observable Universe.
So, in comparison
why does any of this matter?
Shall I go back to that
question I skipped?
Forget it!
We're all just star dust anyway.
(techno music)
- [Voiceover] All right, exam is over.
Hand in your sheets.
(paper rustling)
- Yeah,
that went well.
Yeah.